من مروي الجمل السودان ينضم الينا الان
مراسل الجزيره اسامه سيد احمد
اسامه الانباء تتحدث عن تجدد الاشتباكات
في محيط مطار مروي شمال السودان صباح هذا
اليوم ماذا سجلتم في هذا الاطار
نعم بالفعل تجدد اتجددت الاشتباكات
العنيفه
والمستمره منذ نحو ثلاث ساعات منذ بدايه
الصباح يعني
استيقظ الناس هنا في مدينه مروي وفي القرى
المجاوره لمدينه مروى
باصوات الرصاص وكل انواع الاسلحه تقريبا
في هذه المعركه التي اشتعلت باكرا في
صبيحه هذا اليوم هناك اصوات كثيفه لاسلحه
مختلفه هناك اسلحه خفيفه هناك اسلحه
متوسطه كذلك هناك استخدام كثيف للاسلحه
الثقيله والمدرعات اذا نحن امام مشهد جديد
بعد ان نام السكان هنا على امل ان تنتهي
ينتهي ما وصف هنا بالكابوس الكبير وانعدام
الامن
ليومين متت الا ان هذا الواقع يعني اطل
براسه من جديد ليرسم واقعا قاتما ربما
يعني ارتسم منذ صبيحه هذا اليوم تجددت اذا
الاشتباكات من جديد ما بين قوات الدعم
السريع وما بين القوات الجيش السوداني هذه
الاشتباكات تركزت في منطقه جنوب مطار مروي
الدولي والقاعده الجويه التابعه
للجيش السوداني هنا في مدينه مروي
وسرعان ما يعني تنتقل الى مكان اخر هذه
الاشتباكات
الى يعني شمال منطقه شمال مطار مروي
الدولي هذه الطلقات التي كنا نستمع اليها
قبل نحو يعني قبل دقائق استمرت به بشكل
مستمر وكثيف يعني طيله الثلاث الماضيه
هناك ايضا الاشتباكات وفي بعض الاحيان
ربما تتحول هذه الاشتباكات لعمليه فر وكر
في بعض المناطق اذن يعني قد يمكن ان نقول
ان مسرح هذه العمليات العسكريه يعني تجدد
من جديد وتباين واختلف
وتركز في اكثر من محور كما ذكرنا شمال
المطار وجنوب مطار مروي الدولي الان ربما
نشاهد اعمده الدخان بدات تتصاعد من جهه
مطار من يعني من مكان قربه
القربى من مكان قربه مطار مروي الدولي اذن
هدات قليلا كما تلاحظون هذه الاشتباكات
ولم نعد نستمع اليها بشكل مستمر ولكن
موجوده لا يمكننا ان نقول ان هذه
الاشتباكات بطبيعه الحال قد انتهت ربما
خفت حدتها قليلا وربما هناك تحركات عسكريه
لسيارات مدججه بالسلاح تشارك في هذه
المعركه كما ذكرت ان السكان والجميع هنا
اعتقد ان ما وصف هنا بالكابوس الامن
الكبير والازمه الكبيره التي عايشها
السكان هنا قد انتهت ولكن يعني هذا ربما
خلاف
ما جرى بالفعل عند الساعات الاولى من
صبيحه هذا اليوم او الصباح الباكر
يعني بدا الناس يشاهدون واقعا جديدا
مغايرا لما قالت
الجهات
العسكريه في الجيش السوداني ان كل شيء
تقريبا قد انتهى وتمت السيطره الكامله على
مطار مر الدولي والقاعده الجويه وقامت
قوات الدعم السريع او بالاحرى قد بحسب
مصادر في الجيش السوداني على الانسحاب
الشرق منطقه مطار مروي الدولي بعد ان قام
الجيش السوداني بحسب ذات المصادر بتامين
ممرات امنه استطاعت خلال هذا الممر الامنه
الخروج من مطار مروي الدولي
لاكثر من 110 من سيارات السيارات المنتجه
بالسلاح وتحمل يعني اعداد كبيره من الجنود
كانوا يرتكزون داخل مطار مروي الدولي
والقاعده الجويه ولكن خروج هذه
المجموعات المدججه من قبل القوات الدعم
السريع من مطار مرور الدولي كانت في
معيتهم بحسب المصادر العسكريه في الجيش
السوداني كانت بمعيتهم مجموعه من
العسكريين المصريين بينهم الضباط كانوا
يعني
ياسرونهم
بمعيه عسكريين في الجيش السوداني داخل
مطار مروي الدولي ولكن يعني كنا نتحدث حتى
ليله امس عن مواجهات ربما قد تحدث في طريق
في يعني اثناء عمليه الانسحاب وكلما بعدت
المسافه ما بين مطار مروي الدولي
ومساله الخروج الامين الذي يعتقد اعتقد
الجميع ان هناك كان خروجا امنا ولكن فيما
يبدو ان القوات المنسحبه من مطار الدولي
اتخذت اماكن اخرى
لترتكز فيها وربما هناك يعني
اعداد او عشرات من السيارات المتجدده
بالسلاح جاء التعزيزات عززت القوات
الموجوده والمرتكزه اصلا في عده نقاط جنوب
مطار مروي الدولي فيما يبدو ان هناك كانت
نيه
لمواجهه من جديد ثم عوده للاشتباكات
ومحاوله يعني شيء محاوله عمل عسكري ربما
يعني ربما
محاوله من جديد
للضغط في اتجاه المطار مروي الدولي ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف ما اذا كانت طبيعه
المواجهات طبعا الان تلاحظون ان هناك ليس
هناك اي اصوات للرصاص
والاسلحه التي استخدمت في هذه المعركه
ولكن الوضع يبدو متازيما ومتوترا بشكل
كبير طالما ان بدايه جديده لهذه لهذه
الاشتباكات قد بدات بالفعل
اسامه ما يجري في مطار مروي تحديدا اليوم
وما يتعلق بتجدد المعارك بين الطرفين يفتح
الباب امام الكثير من التساؤلات اشرت الى
انها مواجهات عنيفه وكثيفه الى اي مدى
اختلفت فيها نوعيه
الاسلحه التعبير عن الايام السابقه وايضا
اهميه هذا الموقع بالنسبه لكلاء الطرفين
اهميه مطار مروي وسيطر عليه علما كما ذكرت
بان بيان القوات المسلحه الجيش السوداني
يقول بانه سيطر بالكامل على مطار مروي حتى
اللحظه
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكننا ان نقول ان
تجدد الاشتباكات من جديد صباح اليوم خلال
الثلاث ساعات الماضيه قد تاثر بشكل او
باخر على السيطره القوات المسلحه
السودانيه التي اعلنتها خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه ولكن هذه معطيات ميدانيه
عسكريه ربما تحدد كثير من التفاصيل
اللاحقه ولكن اذا ما حاولنا اجراء مقارنه
بسيطه ما بين البدايه يعني ربما يذكرنا
تذكرنا الاشتباكات
بدايه الاشتباكات من جديد اليوم صباح
اليوم ببدايه الاشتباكات الاولى قبل قبل
يومين البدايه الاولى كانت بشكل كثيف تم
استخدام جميع الاسلحه من الخفيفه ومتوسطه
واسلحه خفيه ثقيله ومدرعات الان ايضا تم
يعني الاستخدام هذه الاسلحه جميعها وبما
فيها المدرعات والاسلحه الثقيله ولكن هدات
الاصوات شيئا فشيئا وتوارث عن اسماء
السكان هنا